[Musique]
laurent berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt est l'invité d'auditions
publiques bonsoir en soirée merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir
d'avoir répondu donc à l'invitation des
chaînes parlementaires de la fp du
figaro et comme chaque semaine bien sûr
les internautes du figaro peuvent réagir
sur le chat deux parlementaires laurent
berger vont venir tout à l'heure pour
vous interpeller ces les députés la
république en marche laurent à petra
exquis qui connaît bien les questions de
travail
et puis le sénateur communiste fabien
gay avec moi pour vous interroger sur
votre colère sociale est d'ailleurs
votre position de syndicats réformistes
peut être fragilisée après les dernières
réformes celle de l'assurance chômage
brigitte boucher tout à l'heure au
rayonnement de chimie est tout de suite
yves thréard et stéphanie le rouge
bonsoir à tous les deux une question sur
la canicule on en fait beaucoup
peut-être peut-être trop je ne sais pas
vous allez pouvoir nous lui en tous les
cas est ce que la cfdt va être vigilante
dans les entreprises de rang berger pour
s'assurer effectivement que et bien les
conditions offertes sont décentes pour
les travailleurs et qui peuvent
éventuellement exercé leur droit de
retrait en tout cas il faut que dans
certains secteurs professionnels il faut
faire attention
évidemment lorsqu'on travaille à
l'extérieur lorsqu'on travaille sans
climatisation il faut il faut faire
attention il faut des mesures
spécifiques
on peut aussi activer le télétravail
pour éviter d'être dans les transports
en commun on sait que c'est
particulièrement difficile dans
certaines régions et particulièrement en
ile de france
donc où il faut être vigilant il faut
être sur vous oui oui on le saura nous
attriste bien sûr dans les entreprises
particulièrement dans certains secteurs
il ya d'abord d'un certains secteurs la
possibilité de on avait les jours
d'intempéries dans certains secteurs
auparavant maintenant les intempéries
dans les travaux publics les intempéries
peuvent stopper s'opérer d'une certaine
manière dans les moments de canicule
mais je crois qu'il faut faire attention
après esquive on en fait trop ou pas moi
j'suis pas météorologue
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faudra à
la fois ne pas faire peur et en même
temps avoir des politiques de prévention
très très forte parce que il ya
effectivement une zone de danger par le
souvenir de 2003 alors je suis d'accord
le gouvernement lui aussi prend le
devant les deux temps sur plusieurs
secteurs mais aussi pour le brevet des
collèges qui devait avoir lieu en milieu
de semaine et qui a été reportée puisque
on sait qu'à toute la semaine est
annoncée caniculaires au 1er au 2
juillet vous trouvez ça excessif ou
outre et ça normal mais c'est difficile
parce qu'on peut pas être spécialiste de
touche pas spécialiste de la santé et de
la météo
donc je fais confiance ça paraît une
mesure très difficile à assumer parce
que enfin en tout cas à prendre parce
que c'est quand même des centaines de
milliers de jeunes qui sont qui sont
concernés mais il l'a fait ça s'applique
voilà je ne crois pas qu'il faut faire
de polémique sur ces sujets là mais
c'est vrai que ça peut avoir des impacts
pour des familles qui avaient prévu de
partir le week-end pour les le début des
vacances romaines domaine qui n'est pas
celui de la météo mais toujours des
études il ya certains enseignants sur
les réseaux sociaux qui disent on va
faire de la rétention sur les notes du
baccalauréat
ces notes du baccalauréat qui doivent
être connus en milieu de semaine
prochaine et qui donc seront retenus par
les enseignants parce que il deux sont
très mécontents de la réforme du lycée
des réformes menées par monsieur blanc
caire où trouvez ça normal
donc ça les ordres des élèves en otages
vous savez faut se méfier les mots de
vocabulaire abusif
mais vous savez les deux fédérations de
l'enseignement de la cfdt le guen et la
fédération de l'enseignement privé sont
très en colère avec aujourd'hui
l'absence de dialogue social dans
l'éducation nationale pour autant en
tout cas l'absence de dialogue social
c'est souvent la responsabilité de celui
qu'on a en face en tout cas y compris
sur la réforme du bac où tout n'est pas
sans doute acheter mais il ya une
absence de dialogue social d'un fort de
ces concertations pour autant pour
autant la cfdt est clair nous sommes
opposés temps à la grève des examens de
la part d'enseignants que de la
rétention il s'agit de jeunes qui sont
en attente de leurs résultats
un peu angoissé sans doute donc je ne
sais pas un bon mode d'action pense pas
que ce soit un moment d'action donc
voilà contre la rétention des notes
effectivement en matière d'assurance
chômage la grande réforme donc dont les
contours ont été dévoilées en fait plus
que les contours les détails mais la
semaine dernière par la ministre du
travail
d'ailleurs il a expliqué qu'elle peut
rien à attendre maintenant que les
choses étaient fichés vous allez pouvoir
lui répondre emmanuel macron a défendu
aujourd'hui la réforme lors de son
déplacement à marseille il s'est rendu
dans une agence de pôle emploi
il a défendu la réforme qui dit il va
dans le sens de ce que veulent les gens
c'est à dire travailler il a lancé aux
gens qui étaient là du travail
on va vous en trouvez donc comment
est-ce que vous réagissez à ce mois je
confirme volontariste je suis fier parce
que les présidents de la république
c'est à dire que les gens ils veulent
travailler
ils veulent travailler dans de bonnes
conditions mais ils subissent aussi de
chômage ils subissent la précarité mais
déclaré travailler
non mais les gens ils subissent du
chômage et de la précarité dans un
certain nombre de secteurs
professionnels
je peux vous donner des exemples très
précis de personnes qui vont être
impactés par cette réforme
ils veulent aussi êtes indemnisés comme
il faut lorsqu'ils subissent des
périodes de chômage et ceux dont il est
question c'est pas simple ce n'est pas
une réforme pour créer de l'emploi
on sait bien que ce n'est pas
l'assurance chômage qui créent l'emploi
c'est pas une réforme pour accompagner
les demandeurs d'emploi même s'il ya des
mesures bénéfiques dans ceux de ce côté
là c'est d'abord de réformes
non non forcé le ce type de peau lance
d'abord nous promet un accompagnement ça
il faudra revoir les modalités c'est une
bonne chose dans attention il faudra
voir les modalités
c'est d'abord une réforme va mieux c'est
d'abord une réforme ça y est c'est trop
sérieux pour qu'on n'écoute pas ça c'est
d'abord une réforme qui va toucher de
façon très très dur un million de
personnes dans leurs indemnisations qui
va les toucher parce que ils ont des
conditions d'accès à l'assurance chômage
beaucoup moins beaucoup plus difficile
qu'auparavant ils auront une
indemnisation moins forte notamment
quand ils seront en situation de
précarité et qu'ils alterneront le
chômage et le travail et ça c'est
inacceptable pour la cgt cette inaction
envers j'ai beaucoup constater quand
même qu on est dans une dans un pays où
le chômage est un véritable problème un
fléau même depuis de très nombreuses
années et c'est bien la raison de toute
façon cela il faut taper sur les
chômeurs alors justement notre système
d'assurance chômage cas probablement des
vertus mais qui a peut-être des défauts
aussi
et bien fait que comparé aux autres pays
européens qui sont peut-être plus
drastiques dans les conditions d'entrée
justement à l'assurance chômage et bien
au moins de chômage que nous donc il ya
peut-être des conclusions en tirer oui
mais d'abord il faut regarder aussi la
situation des travailleurs pauvres dans
l'incertain
deux pays européens qui ont un taux de
chômage moins important mais où il ya du
travail et à l'allemagne
royalement oui notamment deuxièmement
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
travailleurs de salariés sont victimes
de la précarité
l'alternance entre des contrats courts
successifs et donc la besoin d'être
indemnisés entre les deux ça ils ne sont
pas responsables ils n'en sont pas
responsables
et donc si on veut lutter contre la
précarité on ne lutte pas contre les
précaires on lutte contre ceux qui ont
une un nuage abusive de contrat court
exemple le godzilla du malus parce qu'on
le dit effectivement limités dans le
rhône aux paluds s'il est limité dans le
nombre de branches et il est limité pour
l'instant en tout cas dans ce qu'on en
connaît dans son effet parce que vous
savez si c'est une mesure cosmétique ça
sert pas à grand-chose à grand chose
non mais moi je crois que c'est trop
sérieux ou cei ce sont des résultats
c'est de ce sont des situations très
concrètes vécues par les demandeurs
d'emploi ceux qui vont être touchés
c'est par exemple 240000 plutôt jeunes
qui vont pas pouvoir rentrer dans le
système d'assurance-chômage d'année
prochaine
parce qu'ils ont ils n'ont pas la bonne
période de référence le nombre de mois
suffisant pour y rentrer ceux qui vont
être touchés c'est ce ce qui touche
aujourd'hui entre 700 et 900 euros et
qui alterne des contrats courts et qui
ont une indemnisation chômage entre les
deux ceux qui sont touchés ce sont ces
femmes particulièrement qui peuvent
recharger leurs droits parce qu'ils sont
dans les secteurs où il ya beaucoup de
précarité et au bout d'un mois ou pouvez
recharger les droits à l'assurance
chômage
maintenant ce sera plus possible ce sera
au bout de six mois en tout la mire
aussi un million de personnes ceux qui
sont touchés c'est aussi ceux qui vont
subir la dégressivité parce que il
aurait des hauts revenus tout cela
tout cela ça a un impact très concret
dans la vie de femmes et d'hommes d'état
n'est de ville va réforme vous l'avais
déjà dit d'ailleurs mais en même temps
vous affirmé ne pas croire au grand soir
sociale donc comment comment il faut
agir d'abord demain la cfdt devant le
ministère du travail avec la cftc l'unsa
la cgc avec la face attendez je vais
finir ma phrase avec la fage qui est
aussi le plus grand syndicat étudiant
avec
un certain nombre d'associations qui
luttent contre l'exclusion contre la
pauvreté atd quart monde le collectif
alerte qui regroupe tout un tas de
l'association solidarités nouvelles
contre le chômage on va aller on va
aller devant le ministère du travail
pour dire notre indignation
pour dean ordination c'est une des
fonctions du syndicalisme après oui vous
savez le gouvernement il fait cette
réforme en ayant bien conscience que il
ya un certain nombre d'idées comme ça
qui circulent dans la société que
finalement si on veut travailler on
arrive bien finir par trouver du travail
la ministre ne cesse de répondre à un
chômeur ne peut pas gagner plus que mais
ses fans ne sait jamais le répète donc
on sait jamais au cas par cas car c'est
non c'est pas le cas je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui le calcul des droits c'était
vous avez devait avoir fondé c'est un
peu de temps
quatre 4 mois sur les 24 derniers mois
sur les 28 derniers mois oui mais pas
trop mais c'est la vie des gens de ton
par là même bien c'est pas c'est pas de
ces pas de l'écumé des choses c'est de
la vie des gens très va travailler il
faut voilà la clé et donc il ya un
certain nombre de gens alterne des plus
quinze jours travaillé quinze jours de
chômage qu'un jour travaillé quinze
jours de chômage et ils créent des
droits comme ça et au bout d'un moment
quand ils ont du chômage
il touche la moyenne dans l'élimination
ça peut aller jusqu'à 900 euros là ce
dont il est question demain c'est qu'on
revoie le calcul des droits on leur
enlève pas des droits dont on va les
mettre plus longtemps ces personnes vont
passer de 4 900 euros à 450 euros 450
euros il ya deux phénomènes
ça va il ya deux conséquences assad à
bord dites moi comment vit comment on
peut croire à l'intérêt de travailler
leur trou lorsqu on touchera 450 euros
d'indemnisation alors qu'on a touché 900
euros précédemment parce qu'on s'était
créé des droits deuxièmement comment ces
incitatifs à reprendre un travail
alors que c'est à peu près le niveau du
rsa et donc je le dis je le dis c'est
cdc pas c'est une réforme qui est
injuste et qui serait alors ça la cgt
dans ce cas mais parce que la cgt
vous savez cette démence est ce projet
de décret il est illustratif d'une chose
il est illustratif que quand ce sont les
partenaires sociaux qui s'engagent dans
une négociation
et bien c'est plus productive de droit
ça veut dire attendez je vais vous dire
qu'on attendait mais savez vous vous
regardez les photos en fait moi je
regarde le film s'il s'est passé cet
accord
enfin c'est pas cet accord ces décrets
ils remettent en cause l'accord de 2008
l'accord de 2008 il a été créé par la
seule cfdt il a été signé par nous nous
uniquement nous il disait quoi cet
accord il disait un jour travaillé un
jour indemnisé il disait quatre mois sur
les 28 derniers mois ils augmentaient
les conditions d'indemnisation des plus
précaires et notamment des jeunes depuis
2013 on a les droits rechargeables
l'assurance chômage c'est à dire que on
est incité à reprendre un travail parce
qu'on recharge ses droits quand on
reprend tout ça c'est fini c'est fini
c'est la démonstration de quoi c'est que
tous se sont jamais voulu signer je
finis toujours tout ce qu on jamais
voulu signer un accord assurance chômage
eh bien ils ont toujours cru que l'état
pourrait faire devrait faire et bien
quand l'état fait c'est beaucoup moins
favorable c'est la faute des écoutes
beaucoup moins favorable aux demandeurs
de la foire assez grave a dit ça la cgtr
et si les cinq mois pourquoi vous n'avez
pas réussi à vous mettre d'accord mais
vous savez pas ce que je vais vous
expliquer d'abord ce gouvernement il a
décidé de transférer la cotisation
salariés vers de la csg en faisant
passer payé d'ailleurs au passage les
retraités pour l'assurance chômage alors
qu'ils ne sont plus vraiment concerné
alors qu'on aurait pu très bien faire de
la csg sur la dépendance par exemple
mais bref il y avait plus de cotisations
il ya plus de cohésion sociale ensuite
et gagne plus dans la loi avenir
professionnel donc ça dépend la
conception qu'on a de la solidarité dans
la loi avenir professionnel
il a été décidé que toutes les
négociations seraient encadrés par une
lettre de cadrage du gouvernement ce
gouvernement il a fait une lettre de
cadrage en demandant 3,5 milliards
d'économies avec des conditions dans la
lettre impossible à tenir dans une
négociation pourquoi parce que du bonus
malus pour les entreprises et la
restriction du droit des chômeurs de
façon très très forte
nous nous avons engagé une négociation
sincère nous avons commencé par
l'accompagnement parce que ça nous passe
est l'élément le plus positif à ce
moment là le gouvernement certains
gouvernements nous ont dit oui mais
l'accompagnement s'en fiche un peu
parlons des économies on a continué et
puis pendant la négociation alors qu'on
essaie pouvait trouver un accord certes
sans doute moins ambitieux au niveau
budgétaire que ce décret le gouvernement
le patronat a reculé parce que le
président de la république dans un grand
débat rappelez vous a dit on fera le
bonus malus quoi qu'il en coûte
résultat c'est pas vraiment le cas et
donc tout cela n'en existe plus mal
nommé avec
quel impact pour les entreprises qui
vont à partir de quand à partir de 2021
ouais hein et avec quel impact en termes
de extrêmement faible le mal le malus
sera extrêmement fait l'europe risque ça
c'est pour les cdd d'usagé cdd 20 pour
certains d'autres pour certains alors
que ça vous en avez trop dans la
technique même si vous avez utilisé un
mot important leur engagez vous avez
parlé de solidarité
est-ce que là on vous écoute on se dit
mais est ce que vous estimez qu'il y
avait depuis l'origine j'ai pas une
arrière pensée idéologique du
gouvernement il ya de changer de système
c'est-à-dire d'arrivée justement un
système de solidarité nationale et
d'abandonner le système d'assurance
sociale par exemple pour les vols pour
lesquels il a cotisé assez évident ça et
ça peut se discuter
c'est pas une option c'est l'option
d'autres organisations syndicales ça a
été historiquement l'option d'autres
organisations syndicales
moi c'est pas mon option je préfère
quand les questions du travail du
chômage de l'emploi soit traité en trois
parts entre acteurs sociaux partenaires
sociaux mais au-delà de ça ce dont on a
aujourd'hui deux sous jacent assez à
cette réforme et le premier c'est besoin
de faire des économies très forte une
réforme budgétaire mais à outrance parce
que c'est 3 milliards 5 d'économies est
sans doute un certain nombre
d'économistes dit que ce sera plus le
deuxième sous jacent c'est lorsqu'on
veut bien lorsqu'on est au chômage si on
se donne la peine on retrouve facilement
du travail mais ça c'est une vision
erronée et voire même je suis assez
sympathique en disant ça parce que je
pense même que le sous jacent c'est ces
chômeurs il faut les remettre au travail
parce que finalement ils n'ont pas
vraiment un travail propose aujourd'hui
des manuels vaincre hollande c'est parce
que je dis mais c'est un peu ce qui
s'est traduit cette année on va vous en
question ce qui est sûr c'est oui mais
du travail
non non mais oui à condition
d'accompagner de forme et de permettre
d'acquérir des compétences et
deuxièmement à condition que les emplois
disponibles soit des emplois qu'ils
soient pas précaire en permanence est ce
que vous comprenez la logique du
président de la république qui fait
cette réforme qui ne
vous convient pas c'est une certitude et
qui est un discours devant
l'organisation internationale du travail
où il dit justement qu'il faut surtout
pas sacrifier les droits sociaux sur le
l'autel d'un capitalisme de plus en plus
fou et qui avait un discours pour le
coup alors très social que vous avez dû
approuver à ce moment là vous savez il
ya quinze jours j'ai le président l'a vu
et qui fait un discours à l'oit et 10
ans effectivement qu'il n'y a aucun
ajustement budgétaires ou économiques
qui peut justifier de revenir sur les
droits sociaux
il dit aussi que jusqu alors il ya eu
trop d'actions de sachants et qui
faisait qui a acquis ce qui parlait au
supplice et en subissant rattachant et
le lendemain le premier ministre est un
discours de politique générale où il dit
nous avons de grandes ambitions
la transition écologique la justice
sociale le premier chapitre sous la
justice sous le vocable justice sociale
c'est l'assurance chômage
mais je le dis c'est pas du tout
cohérent avec le discours du prénom de
la république à genève
et c'est pas du tout de la justice
sociale ce qui vient de se faire c'est
une réforme profondément injuste et vous
savez ce qui met en colère c'est après
tout il le faut ce qui met en colère
c'est une forme de cynisme
ce cynisme il à double niveau il est
d'abord parce que on dit on sait que les
français ont plutôt être favorable avec
cette réforme parce que finalement ça
répond à un recul pardon de la console
du consentement à solidarité et
deuxièmement ça me met en colère parce
qu'on nous fait croire que les règles
étaient en vigueur c'était pour répondre
à la crise de 2008 moi j'étais un des
négociateurs et ministres du traité un
des négos c'est un mensonge et je le dis
et le terme est fort mais je l'assumé
parce que re lisez ce texte je lis ici
et a aucun élément aucun élément qui
fait référence à la crise le la le lac
hors assurance chômage de fin 2008 que
nous avons signés tout seul parce que ça
me permettait de droits nouveaux
précaires
il vient d'un accord de janvier 2008 sur
la modernisation du marché du travail où
nous avions décidé de mettre ça en place
votre papa vive votre colère et vise
mais votre réponse est faible quand même
parce que vous allez vous réunir demain
ministère du travail mais pourquoi ne
pas vous faire entendre davantage avec
des actions plus spectaculaires mais de
gaza semblement dont personne parce que
parce que moi je ne mens pas je ne sais
pas le faire parce que tout c'est à dire
des faibles non non ça va pas dire qu'on
est faible ça veut dire que très
clairement aujourd'hui ces décrets sont
pas rentrés en application et donc on en
a pas une incarnation totale et c'est
les gens qui vont empêcher de bouger
évidemment ils vont pas bouger parce que
la boue prise parce que le rythme de
création à manifester demain on va
manifester le rappel de voir la
circulation devant vous en savez rien
ouais vous n'en savez rien à l'heure
qu'il est demain nous allons manifester
devant le ministère du travail
ensuite je peux vous assurer que cette
réforme elle va coller comme un scotch
sur une chaussure au gouvernement et
qu'on n'en on en n'est nom sera les
conditions les déclinaisons à chaque
fois qu'on en aura l'occasion et
deuxièmement on va informer les
demandeurs d'emploi aujourd'hui on
commence à le faire mais demandeurs
d'emploi ils ont le sentiment que ça
tout ça est un peu lointain ce que je
comprends mais nous continuerons de fin
2019 et début 2000 va à le faire et nous
agirons autant que possible pour revenir
sur ses formes sur ses ventes
avant je cherche pas un débouché
politique madame je cherchais une
indignation une des fonctions du
syndicat c'est l'indignation je crois
pas la manier trop souvent vous êtes je
suis reconnu pour pas la manier très
souvent et pour être plutôt dans la
nuance
mais ce que je dis ce soir c'est
irréfutable
vous ne trouverez pas une personne pour
vous dire que c'est pas vrai ça va
toucher un million de personnes
ça va toucher les plus précaires ça va
toucher particulièrement les jeunes
ça va toucher les personnes qui sont en
temps partiel imposé et cadets qui sont
pas finis mon énumération ça va toucher
les personnes en temps partiels imposés
qu'ils sont majoritairement des femmes
et ça va toucher les cadres parce que il
faut donner à cette réforme
un semblant de justice sociale parce
qu'on après un peu ce qu'on des plus
hauts revenus
et bien je le dis c'est inacceptable
pour la cfdt vous pouvez trouver la
réponse faible je pourrais vous
promettre des grandes manifestations sur
le sujet je sais très bien que c'est pas
l'option à 7 par exemple et donc
redoubler aujourd'hui et notamment dans
la perspective des prochaines heures et
vous savez où ça joue sur la réforme des
retraites une chose qu'un syndicaliste
je dois jamais oublié ses de s'indigner
quand c'est profondément injuste et je
vais vous dire une chose qui a peut-être
vous étonner
vous savez dans le monde du travail dans
le monde des entreprises là où les
élections se succèdent les unes après
les autres des élections
professionnelles ou la cfdt progresse
comme chacun sait je suis pas sûr que ça
fasse beaucoup d'échos la critique de la
cfdt et le fait qu'on monte fortement si
je le fais c'est vraiment parce que ça
touche à nos valeurs qui sont les
valeurs de solidarité et de justice
sociale combat c'est la retraite c'est
un autre sujet bon c'est un combat mais
c'est un autre sujet et j'espère que le
gouvernement va comprendre que s'il veut
agir seul comme il l'a fait sur cette
réforme d'assurance chômage
et bien il y aura rien qui pourra passer
et la cfdt sera en opposition merci à
tous les deux merci deuxième partie
maintenant d'auditions publiques pour
vous avec les deux parlementaires qui
font leur entrée sur ce plateau comme je
voulais annoncé
messieurs bonsoir installez-vous
l'europe et razès qui vous êtes député
la république en marche d'une heure et
vous êtes le rapporteur de la loi
travail vous êtes spécialiste de ces
questions à vos côtés le sénateur fabien
gay élu de seine-saint-denis merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être là je
vais vous donner la parole vous allez
pouvoir engager le dialogue je ne sais
pas qui va réussir tenter de convaincre
l'autre mais un internaute du figaro
vous interroge laurent berger blanc
pascal les français ne plébiscitent plus
aujourd'hui les partis politiques et il
dit il en sera de même pour les
syndicats oui il en est de même
potentiellement pour les médias aux en
est de même pour l'ensemble de nos
institutions et demain c'est quoi
l'avenir
c'est une société autoritaire c'est une
société sans acteurs sociaux sans élu
démocratiquement élu non c'est moi c'est
pas ma vision de la société
donc cette défiance à l'égard des
institutions de beaucoup d'institutions
c'est plutôt un danger qu'une forme de
réjouissance que les uns ou les autres
pourraient pourrait avoir si on va vers
ça je vous le dis on va vers une société
autoritaire ou sans doute les partis
extrémistes notamment l'extrême droite
fera son miel
ben moi c'est pas ce que je souhaite
pour notre démocratie donc ça veut dire
que faut pas s'en réjouir faut que
chacun agisse pour devenir plus
performants répondant plus aux attentes
des uns et des autres et notamment à ses
cibles entre guillemets c'est à dire les
travailleurs pour nous pour les
accompagner plutôt que de se réjouir
d'une défiance généralisée qui mine
notre démocratie des dangers de la
société de défiance laurent à 80 s qui
vous avez écouté tout à l'heure donc la
première partie de cette émission avec
les arguments très forts utilisés par
notre invité qui accusent la misère de
mensonges
que répondez vous vous avez passé du
temps effectivement sur la réforme sur
le chômage et puis la nouvelle
convention et décrets qui sortiront tout
à l'heure bon je pense qu'il faut
d'abord peut-être remettre cette réforme
dans un contexte global celle de la
transformation de notre modèle social et
les différentes étapes que nous
construisons et y compris avec les
partenaires sociaux y compris d'ailleurs
avec la cfdt
même s'il a justement j'ai bien compris
que les partenaires sociaux n'était pas
arrivé à se mettre d'accord et le
gouvernement a pris ses responsabilités
transformation du manioc social juste
s'est très vite mais en quatre temps le
dialogue social dans les entreprises ce
qu'on appelle les ordonnances pénicaud
la formation pour tous le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
l'assurance chômage et la nouvelle
grosso et puis le quatrième temps nous
parlera peut-être commencer juste avant
que londres sur ce plateau sur la grande
réforme des retraites là on fait de la
pédagogie mais n'est pas convaincant
pendant l'été écoutez je ne sais pas sur
quoi laurent berger pense que
le gouvernement aurait menti je pense
peut-être en trouver d'autres arguments
non mais c'est moi je comprends j'ai
compris il y a eu les ordonnances
travail qui dans les entreprises créent
beaucoup de perturbations sur le sujet
même du dialogue social parce que leur
mise en oeuvre est extrêmement chaotique
et souvent se fait en termes de -10 en
termes de de conditions et de dialogue
social de moyens syndicaux par exemple
mais on voit bien je crois qu'on aura
une année 2010 neuf qui sera moins
performante sur le dialogue social
d'entreprise qu'elle l'était
précédemment ce qui est quand même un
comble l'année qui suit les ordonnances
travail la réforme de la formation
professionnelle il ya des choses
potentiellement intéressantes mais leur
mise en oeuvre
la mise en oeuvre est extrêmement lente
parce que notamment la mise en oeuvre
des opérateurs de compétences a pris
beaucoup de temps parce que ça a été
compliqué avec les branches
professionnelles
et puis cette réforme d'assured oncle à
on avait des désaccords
on avait des points d'accord mais on a
aussi des désaccords on les a exprimés
là si on réagit aussi vivement sur
l'assurance chômage c'est que cette
réforme est injuste et touche aux plus
fragiles et donc veut revendre et que
vous revendiquez un changement de modèle
le cil changement de modèle c'est pour
passer d'un modèle de solidarité
interprofessionnelle un modèle qu'on
pourrait qu'ils n'étaient pas un modèle
nordique loin s'en faut mais qui
pouvaient ils prétendre c'est en tout
cas ce qu'on nous dit parfois
là c'est plutôt un modèle anglo saxon
qui est en train d'être construit très
clairement de mon point de vue c'est un
modèle anglo saxon c'est à dire un
modèle où c'est le culte de l'individu
et l'individu si on leur donne les
moyens il a un peu se débrouiller et le
filet de sécurité est extrêmement
minimale voilà c'est ça que je remets en
cause juste une réaction
je pense que le roux marché sera
d'accord avec moi pour dire que quand on
met quatre mille conseillers pour les
emplois en accompagnement de l'ensemble
des demandeurs d'emploi
on n'est pas dans une vision à
l'anglo-saxonne on est dans une vision
de l'accompagnement et ça aussi c'est un
élément fort de la réforme le statut
moi j'étais conseiller en insertion
professionnelle les demandeurs d'emploi
longue durée je sais ce que c'est
et quelle est leur situation le volet
accompagnement est plutôt un volet
séduisant et on rajoute 1000 postes
à pôle emploi parce qu'il était prévu
dans les 4000 postes dont vous parlez en
à 3000 qui devait être supprimée qui
finalement ne sont pas supprimés
la question qui sera posée c'est les
conditions de la mise en oeuvre de cet
accompagnement si on est capable de le
faire de façon individuelle renforcer
très bien si c'est la poudre aux yeux on
le verra mais la cfdt elle s'y engagera
dans la négociation avec pôle emploi
avec entre l'unedic et pôle emploi on
fera on fera le travail mais mais mais
mais cnse n'est pas équivalent à la
baisse de droits d'indemnisation qui est
en train de s'opérer
fabien gay oui moi monsieur bergé j'ai
accepté de venir ce soir parce que je
pense que dans le moment politique et
social dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui il est très important que
des forces politiques et des forces
syndicales qui n'ont pas le même rôle
dans la société et je les partage bien
en tout cas nous un dialogue constructif
alors sur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage je fais je dirais le même qu'au
stade vous c'est à dire qu on a une
vision où on va amener le gouvernement
le bâton et la carotte c'est à dire
qu'on pense que c'est en précarisant les
gens combat par miracle leur donner
envie de retourner au travail comme si
les deux millions cinq cent mille à 6
millions suivant comment calcule
n'aurait pas envie de travailler
mais c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un
chômage organisé et qu'en réalité c'est
pas en précarisant plus les gens qu'on
leur permettra de retourner au travail
et sur ce point on est d'accord mais moi
le point que j'ai envie parce qu'on a
beaucoup discuté de ça dans la première
partie c'est sur la méthode du
gouvernement
vous dites je suis fâché parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
concertation sociale
sur ce point mais j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement alors peut-être ça c'est
mon constat et j'ai envie d'avoir un
dialogue avez-vous depuis 2010 est elle
arrivée d' emmanuel macron sera un
certain nombre de réformes
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de dialogue
social malheureusement sur la réforme de
la sncf sur les différentes réformes qui
ont eu lieu
malheureusement on a vu que le dialogue
social avec les forces syndicales
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
jamais je me permets les dialogues
région attendez je finis je me
permettrai jamais juger les forces
syndicales je sais ce que c'est d'être
salarié et d'être syndiqué donc jamais
je me permets
mais pour le coup on voit que sur un
certain nombre de réformes il n'y a pas
eu ce dialogue social que vous appelez
de vos voeux
est ce que vous pensez est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire ce que vous avez gagné
depuis le 17 dans le dialogue social est
ce que vous espérez maintenant sur les
prochaines réformes
on nous annonce la retraite et vous le
savez on déjà c'est la réforme par point
à la fin de la retraite par les
syndicalistes
ouais donc très clairement déjà je ne me
situe pas dans une démarche politique
vous avez fait les 66 positions hurle un
jeune j'avais le web on va y revenir
mais c'est ce sont des
mais nous ne nous sommes pas dans une
démarche politique nous sommes dans une
démarche syndicale
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'un syndicaliste
quand il dans une entreprise il choisit
pas son interlocuteur patronal employeur
lorsqu un syndicaliste est dans une
position interprofessionnelle nationale
comme je le suis il choisit pas son
interlocuteur politique mais il lui
reconnaît sa légitimité c'est la
légitimité procuré par le vote dans une
entreprise c'est une loutre légitimité à
partir de là nous bat tout ce qu'on peut
pousser on le pousse et donc ça veut
dire qu'on regarde pas forcément de qui
ça vient mais on le pousse et dans la
dernière période c'est vrai c'est vrai
que la place des corps intermédiaires
enfin des acteurs sociaux et notamment
du syndicalisme à la parfois été remis à
l'âge parfois été remise en cause
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait une
volonté de faire autrement et le premier
acte qui est posée c'est pas le cas
c'est paca et donc oui il ya des choses
qu'on a obtenu mois le programme
investissement compétences je trouve que
c'est une démarche intelligente sur la
lutte contre la pauvreté
même si la mise en oeuvre est un peu
compliqué il ya eu des choses positives
j'en prends un exemple la le
renforcement de l'insertion par
l'activité économique
moi j'y suis très attaché il ya eu des
choses dans la stratégie pauvreté en
septembre voilà donc nous on juge sur
pièce là on le juge sur pièce si j'étais
d'accord je le dirai je suis en
désaccord je le dis mais le rêve le
syndicalisme réformiste que vous êtes là
incarner l île recherche du résultat est
encore sa raison d'être à leurs
maquereaux mais oui je sais maintenant
comment dire ce qu'on en faisait le plus
grand
ce qu'on est en train de vivre c'est la
démonstration que quand le dialogue
social s'opère et bien on peut créer des
droits intelligents qui sont des
compromis lorsque le dialogue social ne
s'opère pas c'est compliqué et donc moi
ce que je dis c'est que la cfdt ont la
critique quand elle passe des compromis
qui ont la critique quand il crie trop
fort la cfdt est juste sur pièce juste
sur pièce au regard de ce que sont ces
valeurs et ces objets qu'ils soient je
pense lorsque les sénateurs qui avec
j'ai parlé de mon nom mais avec force et
clarté le cas maintenant mais je pense
que je pense c'était quand même
intéressant de se dire moi je voudrais
pas qu'on caricature la position de la
cellulite et ou de rouen verger
moi je crois c'est ce que je voulais
dire au début je crois que on a avec la
cfdt
un syndicat qui est réformiste qui a la
volonté de construire certaines choses
d'ailleurs qui parfois je crois qu'une
partie de la colère si j'exclus bien la
décoder c'est qu'ils soient encore plus
acteur de cette construction
si on prend juste un exemple ça répondra
peut-être mais c'était pas mon rôle à la
question de mon voisin sénateurs je
crois que si on prend juste mais que ça
vous tient à coeur aussi si on prend
juste l'égalité femmes comme l'index
aujourd'hui qui existent d'abord c'est
une vraie négociation des partenaires
sociaux c'est un vrai travail de
dialogue social qui a été repris à son
compte par le gouvernement et qui a pris
les décrets qui vont bien pour que ça se
mettre en route
aujourd'hui cet index une forme
d'indicateurs qui permet à tout un
chacun pour les entreprises jusqu'à 1000
salariés à partir de 10 salariés puis
ensuite on va passer à 250 ensuite 50
d'avoir une mesure de la qualité la
politique de l'égalité femmes hommes 25
% d'écart en moyenne quelque chose
d'extrêmement il n'y a pas que sur le il
n'y a pas que sur les salaires mais vous
avez raison de souligner cet écart sur
les rails mais justement au lieu d'être
sur une généralité grâce à cet index
on va pouvoir dire cette entreprise
allait vertueuse où elle n'est pas
vertueuse donc moi je crois que c'est un
exemple de ce qu'on peut arriver à co
construire avec des parisiens est
réformiste jeu complet
ce berger pour un pour nous répondre
mais sur l'égalité femmes hommes qui est
une grande cause du quinquennat nous
annoncer j'ai lu avec attention
l'interview de marlène schiappa dans le
parisien ce dimanche qui nous dit que
elle veut mettre en grande cause la
question des femmes de chambre mais oui
il me les rendre elle a raison sur la
question de la visibilité d'un certain
nombre de travailleuses et travailleurs
mais la réalité c'est que de quoi
souffrent les femmes de chambre de tous
est invisible
c'est d'abord de la question du salaire
et on sort d'une crise sociale
il ya eu deux discours de politique
générale à l'assemblée nationale 1 au
sénat et à jamais à aucun moment on a
parlé la question des salaires
l'augmentation nous venons de passer la
loi pacte de 200 articles où on vient de
dire la loi pas que c'est très important
il ya deux cents ans en 200 articles sur
l'entreprise et à aucun moment nous
n'avons pu parler de la question des
salaires et je pense que le syndicaliste
qui est monsieur bergé la question de
l'augmentation de salaire pour que les
gens puissent vivre dignement
je pense qu'il a à coeur là on a d'abord
il ya une partie du débat qui entre deux
parlementaires qui est passionnant
d'ailleurs ce pas moi de les choses qui
sont l'index index sur l'égalité
professionnelle
c'est une obligation de moyens qui
n'existait pas auparavant
on l'a souligné on a souligné les
intérêts tout comme l'organisation
internationale du travail vient de deux
aussi d'adopter un texte sur la lutte
contre
les violences et le harcèlement au
travail et la france s'y est engagée
très bien le problème c'est que il faut
que ça suive sur l'ensemble des sujets
hier cette logique de discuter avec les
acteurs sociaux ce soit sur l'ensemble
des sujets et qu'on leur laisse une part
d'autonomie aussi pour agir sur d'autres
ensuite sur la question des salaires moi
j'ai regretté dans la loi pacte que s'il
n'y a pas de dispositif beaucoup plus
contraignant sur la transparence des
salaires dans une entreprise d'ailleurs
je pense que c'était une erreur je l' ai
dit à plusieurs reprises parce que si on
l'avait fait ça donnait aussi une
volonté
pourquoi eux de montrer celles de
montrer votre éditeur vous savez qu'il y
avait une opposition qui avait été fait
d'aller beaucoup plus loin et je pense
que ce qu'il aurait fallu le faire et
après la question de la rémunération des
des augmentations de salaires la
répartition des richesses c'est un vrai
sujet aujourd'hui posée dans les
entreprises c'est clair c'est un sujet
de branche et d'entreprise qu'il faut
qu'il faut saisir davantage
la grande différence c'est entre les
grandes et les moyennes et les petites
entreprises
c'est à dire que les politiques
salariales dans un certain nombre de
grandes entreprises de secteurs qui vont
plutôt bien c'est vrai parce que c'est
pas de général il y a de la négociation
est ce qu'on appelle la négociation
annuelle obligatoire
le problème c'est les négociations de
branche qui peine pour tous les salariés
des petites et moyennes entreprises
et c'est ça qu'il faut revaloriser
aujourd'hui faut redonner du poids à la
branche là dessus et ceux qui manquent
d'être fait de mon point de vue un tout
petit point parce qu'on est vraiment
dans le coeur je crois des échanges avec
avec laurent berger ces négociations de
branche sur ces périmètres qui sont
donnés d'ailleurs par les ordonnances
que nico par les ordonnances qui réforme
le dialogue social aux branches
c'est vraiment un lieu et un zone de
négociations ouvertes et ça n'est
possible que si les branches sont
regroupés homogène ce qui est laid
démarche actuelle puisqu'on et on était
à plus de 700 branche on va arriver à
moins de 300 est un objectif est
d'arriver
le truc c'est que les ordres les
ordonnances travail elles ont redit le
rôle de la branche qui existaient
précédemment il existait précédemment
citoyenne 13 2 mai mais aujourd'hui par
exemple il ya un sujet c'est laid ça
peut être un peu technique c'est lé
salaire minimum horaire
il ya une volonté
de les faire disparaître de la
prérogative de la branche tout le monde
est contre les organisations syndicales
les organisations patronales tout le
monde est content
donc faut pas toucher à sa fin donner la
possibilité à chaque branche de fixer
les salaires minimum horaire pour
notamment les plus basses les plus
basses rémunérations
donc voilà c'est des sujets très
techniques tout ça très concret surtout
tout cela ça nécessite qu'on discute
qu'on soit écouté qu'on soit entendue et
pas simplement qu'on soit informé des
décisions qui sont prises et je le dis
s'il n'y a pas un changement radical de
méthode de façon dont on considère les
acteurs sociaux je crois qu'on n'aura
pas pris conscience de la crise très
grave qu'on a traversé ces derniers mois
et l'exécutif à changer d'attitude c'est
ça il vaut dix nations à vous de ces
serres vous dit le message me suis le
député alors vous l'entendez message où
on vous demande de changer de méthode
écoutez la méthode en tous les cas mais
pour ce qui est des parlementaires que
je représente la méthode on est on est à
chaque fois que c'est possible et je
crois que c'est vrai aussi avec tous les
partenaires sociaux qui souhaitent en
échanges et en dialogue
j'entends bien que la négociation n'a
pas pu arriver aboutir c'est pour ça que
le gouvernement a pris ces décrets parce
qu'il a négociations avaient abouti dans
les conditions du niveau ses leçons qui
était impossible pour vous dire des
choses très franchement quand il a fait
l'année de cadrage il pensait que
c'était impossible et qu'on avait pas
déjà où ce sont des puits lorsque la
crise et gilet jaune a démarré une des
velléités ça serait mieux qu'ils gèrent
la difficulté plutôt que ça nous
reviennent et puis finalement on a
attendu parce que le gouvernement était
plus long que le temps accordé aux
partenaires sociaux pour négocier
et lorsqu'on arrive à ceux à ses projets
de décrets je vous le dis c'est une
situation
ça ne répond pas à la situation sociale
des demandeurs de radio et ça aggrave
leur situation c'est ça qui est
totalement inacceptable
bon il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur ce
débat mais on n'a que vingt minutes
parce que vous dites ça marche moi
j'avais le deuxième sujet très rapide
monsieur bergé c'est sur le référendum
adp
j'ai bien écouté votre intervention chez
jean jacques bourdin vous avez d'abord
dit on n'est pas d'accord avec les
conditions de la privatisation avant de
dire nous sommes engagés contre la
privatisation mais vous vous avez dit de
façon personnelle que vous hésitiez a
signé pour le référendum
moi je tiens à vous dire que font
évidemment je suis engagée contre la
privatisation pour plusieurs raisons les
aspects sociaux les aspects économiques
les aspects environnementaux
mais la question qui nous est posée
c'est que pour la première fois 246
parlementaires de tous bords politiques
veulent donner la parole au peuple
depuis 1986 il ya 1500 privatisation qui
à chaque fois dégrade les conditions
pour les usagers devenus des clients est
la variable d'ajustement
je finis je finis mais il ya 8000
salariés adp 130 milles sur les plates
formes aéroportuaires d'aéroports de
paris qui eux demandent un référendum je
vais jouer vous poser cette question là
est opposé à la privatisation bp parce
que l'aéroport de paris au delà d'être
extrêmement important a aussi d'énormes
enjeux fonciers etc
donc nous sommes opposés pas deuxième
point il ya un référendum qui est lancée
par des forces politiques par des
parlementaires
oui mais des parlementaires fanfare des
parlementaires qui est là sur lequel la
cfdt n'a pas à se prononcer chacun est
libre de signer ou non ce référendum et
c'est un peu comme dans une élection cdt
donne pas de consignes hormis lutter
contre l'extrême droite et là en cela
moi je ferais bien ce que je veux et je
garderai ça de la même manière que je
garde mon vote secret je garderai ça
secret mais ça veut pas dire que sur les
je crois qu'il ya d'autres modes il ya
le référendum on verra ce que ça donnera
et il ya aussi le mode d'action pour
lutter contre la privatisation des
aéroports de paris notamment par
l'action des salariés d'aéroports de
paris
malheureusement on est phone tous
engagés dans l'intersyndicale pour leur
faire une dernière dont la cfdt a évoqué
la fin mais c'était plus pour relancer
les rumeurs j'ai à la fois lui demander
les cse on est allé conseil socio
économiques qui remplace les instances
représentatives du personnel
on est à plus de 23000 au mois de mai
les entreprises doivent se mettre au
clair là dessus d'ici le 31 décembre
et on a du mal à avancer dans le conseil
d'entreprise et je crois que ce sujet-là
tenait à coeur aussi à la cfdt d'avant
cas la majorité présidentielle le nombre
de ces essais mis en place sont très
très faible par rapport au potentiel
d'entreprise qui devrait le mettre en
place
et là quand ça se met en place et dans
des conditions très très très dégradé la
plupart du temps il ya eu seulement un
accord d'entreprise pour 10 mise en
place de cs
pour le reste c'est le minimum et donc
moi je le dis ça va pour créer de
beaucoup de blocages beaucoup de
situations difficiles dans le dialogue
social sur le conseil d'entreprise c'est
une forme de co détermination dans
laquelle on souhaiterait s'engager
force est de constater qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de maturité du côté des
entreprises sur le sujet la cfdt
lorsqu'elle ne pourrait avoir
l'opportunité le fera mais c'est pas
malheureusement beaucoup à l'ordre du
jour nous on est plutôt en train de se
battre pour que le dialogue social
subissent dans les entreprises parce que
la mise en place d c est ce encore une
fois c'est très très difficile et ça se
fait dans les conditions très dégradées
merci messieurs voyez-vous le dialogue
social a eu lieu sur ce plateau aura
beaucoup entrent en marche et une
rondeur merci messieurs dernière partie
maintenant avec nos deux concerts qui
arrive brigitte boucher et oriane
mancini
une question d'un internaute du figaro
justement nous avons parlé des gilet
jaune xavier demander où en est la cfdt
avec les gilet jaune à on pourrait aussi
se demander où en sont les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui quel bilan vous tirer de ces
longs mois de manifestations ces actes
répétés et puis soyons le bilan il est
encore une fois est ce que j'ai dis
souvent il ya des colères légitime
connaissait donc lié aux fractures
territoriales aux fractures sociales aux
inégalités fiscales
et puis il y a des formes de colère qui
se sont manifestés parfois de façon
pacifique parfois non ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on voit bien toutes les limites
d'un mouvement qui n'est sûr des colère
légitime je le répète mais qui peine à à
prioriser ses revendications à les
porter à désigner des représentants et
donc je crois je renouvelle sa c'est
cette colère il faut que l'on passe de
la colère à l'engagement et il ya toutes
les organisations syndicales
associatives pour relayer ses
préoccupations régis taurian bonsoir
organes premières questions questions
sur les intermittents hier muriel
pénicaud était l'invité du grand jury et
quand on lui demandait pourquoi le
gouvernement ne demandait pas d'efforts
aux intermittents
elle a répondu que c'était aux
partenaires sociaux de prendre la main
qu est ce que vous pensez de cette
housse fait hurler je crois que ça nous
a tous fait hurler le gouvernement dès
le départ a dit touchez pas aux
intermittents touchez pas au régime des
intermittents du spectacle et je vais
vous dire c'est d'autant plus scandaleux
cette affirmation qui est fausse
d'autant plus scandaleuse il n'y a
jamais eu la question des intermittents
sur la table parce qu'on nous a demandé
de ne pas la traiter et cette
affirmation elle est d'autant plus fort
que moi j'ai fini la réunion avec le
premier ministre j'ai pas là j'ai passé
de l'habitude de raconter les réunions
mais la réunion avec le premier je vais
vous dire ce que je lui ai dit à la fin
je lui ai dit j'ai repris la parole dit
monsieur le premier ministre madame mise
vous qui êtes des femmes et des hommes
de culture pouvez vous nous dire dans
quel festival il faut se rendre cette
année car nous avons bien compris que
vous ne vouliez pas toucher à ceux à ce
régime des intermittents qui est aussi
un régime de permis tant ce com vous
l'employez il n'y a pas eu de réponse je
le dis c'est autant et peut discuter
pendant des heures sur fallait-il ou pas
touchés et de telle manière le régime d
avec celui tennis comme on dit c'est à
dire l'intermittent du spectacle
autant on peut le discuter autant le
fait de nous mettre ça sur le dos c'est
totalement inacceptable totalement
inacceptable et c'est cynique
parce que c'est le gouvernement je le
répète qu'il n'a pas voulu y toucher il
a ses raisons mais ils ont baissé parce
que c'est une lâcheté qui s'ajoutent aux
mensonges
la raison c'est que c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui de toucher à un système qui
est très coûteux pour l'assurance
chômage il faut le dire est qu'ils
étaient utilisés notamment par
l'audiovisuel et notamment par
l'audiovisuel public et bien sûr la zone
euro déficit de sens de courage pour
traiter ce sujet oui c'est pas une
question de courage absent un courage
sans doute et surtout la déloyauté total
dans ses propos je le dis on voit bien
vous avait durci le ton face au
gouvernement on se pense que c'est
annonciateur avant la réforme des
retraites
est ce que vous vous êtes prêts à
accepter cette idée qui tourne d'un hd
qui libre dont le premier ministre a
parlé lors de son discours de politique
générale à l'assemblée nationale 1h
d'équilibré se situerait autour de 64
ans d'abord je contredis ce que vous
avez dit en introduction de votre
question nous avons pas durci le ton en
attendant pour se préparer à une autre
question
c'est pas ma façon de faire moi j'ai
durci le ton parce que je ne supporte
pas que les demandeurs d'emploi
trinquent comme ils vont traquer donna
médiatique les deux ans mais n'avait
d'urso j'ai pas du style tôt j'ai
simplement dit que ce qui se passe ce
sont des prénoms des gens que je
rencontre qu on rencontre tous et qui
vont subir demain des deux grosses
pertes d'indemnisation parce qu'il ya
cette réforme c'est pour ça que je durci
le ton parce que la justice sociale me
rend dingue et y aménager ses parents
font cette réforme profonde dans les
réformes
l'assurance chômage la réforme des
retraites je la connais pas entendez
parler des tâches d'équilibré pour nous
avons été largement concertée de
consulter et nous travaillons nous avons
travaillé y compris et tout le monde
tout le monde toutes les organisations
syndicales avec des documents fournis
par le haut commissariat sur cette tâche
d'équilibrer vous dire nous nous pensons
qu'il ya pas besoin d'une réforme
paramétrique soit le sur l'assurance sur
les retraites n'a pas besoin de toucher
à l'âge déquilibre ou à la durée de
cotisation je rappelle que la duration
et continue d'augmenter
selon la loi de touraine de 2013 et donc
je crois que ce gouvernement il ferait
une profonde
or s'il voulait faire à la fois une
réforme qualitative pour réduire les
inégalités inhérentes au système des
retraites qui touche les femmes qui
touchent ce conte et carrières hachées
qui touche ce qu'on travaillait un peu
dans le public et dans le privé ce qu'on
appelle les polypensionnés etc etc et en
même temps faire une réforme qui soit
une réforme budgétaire
donc je le dis ni dans le plfss qui
s'annonce à la rentrée ni dans la
réforme des retraites en tant que tel
qui sera sans doute à la fin de l'année
ou ou en début d'année prochaine
il peut être question de d'éléments
paramétrique la cfdt l'a dit je le
réaffirme qu'il faut mettre fin aux 42
régimes spéciaux mais c'est inhérent
c'est totalement logique c'est pas ça ça
fait cesser des mots qui ont été
prononcés à l'assemblée scène et tout le
monde avait déjà en tête puisque de
toute façon si on veut un régime
universel qui veut pas dire régime
unique donc on pourra garder ses
spécificités professionnelles
c'est évident ben il est évident qu'il y
aura un régime universel mais vous savez
je suis persuadé qu'un certain nombre de
ressortissants des régimes spéciaux ont
beaucoup à y gagner parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de fantasmes aussi sur ces
régimes spéciaux mais vous le dites vous
invitez vous avez été longuement
concertée par jean paul delevoye vous
aviez l'air plutôt d'accord avec ce que
propose jean paul delevoye qu'est ce que
vous craignez le gouvernement la philo
il s'agit de la réforme
vous savez la philosophie qui de la
réforme telle qu'elle est construite
aujourd'hui la cfdt c'est pas la qualité
s'est pas rallié la cfdt depuis 2003
nous disons qu'il faut une réforme
systémique des retraites pour les rendre
le système plus juste et plus lisible et
donner davantage de justice au sein du
régime
donc on s'est pas rallié et 7 mois j'ai
entendu le 10 octobre dernier
madame la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités et et monsieur delevoye nous
dire il n'y aura pas d'élément
paramétrique dans cette réforme en
termes d'allongement de dur de l'âge ou
d'allongement de la durée l'action faire
une réforme financière et donc il n'y
aura pas de réformes financer c'est sûr
dit donc on lui ont leur dis chiche se
dévoue à cet engagement et travaillons
sur une réforme de moyen long terme pour
rendre le système plus il n'y a pas une
forme d'hypocrisie de la part du
gouvernement de dire finalement avec un
hd kiliba 64 ans soit on s'arrête avant
et on a un malus soit engagée travailler
ce sera une forme je sais pas s'il sera
d'hypocrisie mais ça sera une réforme
qui sera inacceptable pour la cfdt
si il faut le travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
sinon il faut un malus sait mais ce
serait inacceptable
mais ce que j'ai entendu dans le
discours du premier ministre dans son
discours de politique générale c'est il
faudra inciter les gens à travailler
plus c'est différent que sanctionner les
personnes
ça veut dire à mannus un bonus potentiel
et on n'est pas le règne non nous on ne
réclame pas mais c'est encore très
différent de donner une décote un malus
pour les gens qui vont partir avant 62
ans ou avant un mot sur une autre
réforme celle de la fonction publique
examinée en ce moment au sénat la
semaine dernière olivier dussopt pts a
fermé la porte des gel du point d'indicé
qu'est ce que vous en pensez moi je
pense toujours dans ces cas-là aux
salariés aux agents publics que je
rencontre dans les hôpitaux dans
l'éducation nationale dans la police
dans les fonctions publiques
territoriale et qui considère qu' on
attend beaucoup d'eux on parle beaucoup
d'eux qu'il faut qu'il se redéploie il
faut qu'ils agissent on leur dit vous
êtes courageux quand il ya des drames
qui sont vécues dans notre pays et puis
on leur dit mais par contre maintenant
on peut pas vous augmentez on peut rien
pour vous il ya un malaise profond
on parlait tout à l'heure des
enseignants qui veut donc certains
disent qu'il faut faire de la rétention
je ne soutiens pas vous l'avez bien
compris cela
mais on a aussi pensé aujourd'hui un
certain non en a eu de mouvement dans
l'est on a le mouvement dans les
urgences on a des mécontentement très
fort dans le secteur par exemple de la
répression des fraudes on est très
content quand on soulève une
un acte illégal pour la production de
viande ou je ne sais quoi mais n'empêche
qu'on réduit leurs moyens tout ça ça
veut dire qu'à un moment donné on
considère que les agents publics qui
sont extrêmement utiles mais par contre
quand on parle de au global on dit que
ce sont des gens qui coûtent trop cher
donc faut savoir ce qu'on veut vous
savez je parlais de la solidarité tout à
l'heure le premier élément de la
solidarité dans un pays c'est l'accès
aux services publics et c'est la
capacité à avoir des services publics
accessibles pour l'ensemble de la
population
faut savoir ce qu'on veut et donc y
compris leurs connaissances elle parle
elle passe par une politique salariale
de les deux notions sont des salaires du
privé et du public on est à peu près
équivalent dont certains disent alors en
six occasions salaire à qualification
égale vous savez quand vous êtes vous
êtes vous êtes fort en maths
je prends un exemple vaut mieux vous
aviez travaillé dans l'industrie que
vous alliez travaillé comme enseignant
en mathématiques pourtant on en a besoin
parce que vous êtes largement moins bien
payé et c'est vrai dans beaucoup
d'endroits regarder dans les hôpitaux on
a du mal enfin dans les hôpitaux on a du
mal à recruter aujourd'hui des aides
soignants et des aides soignantes parce
que difficultés du métier absence de
reconnaissance
ça passe par une augmentation du point
d'indicé ce que vous dites alors
qu'officiellement on nous dit oui ça
n'empêche pas les biens cessèrent d'être
augmenté régulièrement
willy du helmand
mais l'augmentation oui mais il ya
beaucoup en tout cas les rémunérations
pour beaucoup d'agents des fonctions
publiques est en deçà de les compétences
qu'ils développent et je crois qu'il
faut entendre une forme de malaise qui
se cristallisent encore aujourd'hui en
fait tout cela c'est aussi un problème
de pouvoir d'achat finalement vous aviez
formulé 66 proposition avec nicolas
hulot pour un pouvoir de vivre un
grenelle du pouvoir de vie vous aviez
même demander ça au gouvernement vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir été entendu
là-dessus non pas suffisamment nous
étions dix neuf organisations s'étaient
pas à koh nicolas hulot et et laurent
bergé s'est tu c'était une avance de
neuf organisations aujourd'hui nous
sommes quarante quatre organisations 44
organisations et regardez la liste de
ces organisations toutes plus
constructive les unes que les autres
c'est à dire que c'est pas une démarche
politique comme j'ai entendu ce n'est
pas une démarche que je vous dit
peut-être avez-vous voté l'école c'est
une démarche n'en savait rien mais
peut-être nicolas non mais nicolas hulot
il a été il a été agréablement donc non
le leur n'est pas une prise de position
non c'est pas une construction politique
d'accord c'est une construction pour
allier de la justice sociale avec de la
transition écologique
soixante six propositions nous nous
demandons à être reçus reçu à l'elysée
sur ces propositions ce que nous n'avons
pas ce qui n'a pas encore eu lieu et ont
reçu est reçu à matignon
non c'est pas une fin de non-recevoir
c'est pas de réponse c est reçu à
matignon pour comporte ses propositions
au conseil
non j'ai pas dit ça mousse et
franchement à titre personnel je suis
très bien comme ça incognito il n'y a
pas de problème non ce que je veux ce
que nous savons nous savons que nous
avons fait une nous avons précisé huit
propositions
dernièrement que nous avons rendu public
dans une conférence de presse la semaine
dernière avec ses 44 organisations
vous savez ce qui est en jeu c'est de
savoir si on veut que l'épisode qu'on a
vécu cette année soit le même se
renouvelle sans cesse avec une
crispation de la société avec des
risques démocratiques et sociaux
extrêmement grave ou si on veut
construire du commun si on veut
construire une société plus apaisée et
moi je suis ce militant comme les autres
responsables des organisations en
question
je suis ce militant du co
de la solidarité d'une société qu'ils
sachent où elle veut aller
c'est à dire vers un mot une performance
économique mais respectueuse de
l'environnement et respectueuse de
l'humain et c'est ça qu'on a voulu
construire à travers ses 60 et vient pas
que des politiques publiques soit les
10% les plus pauvres de la politique
injuste
ça veut dire surtout qu'une société elle
se grandit quand elle considère que
c'est en s'occupant de ceux qui sont le
plus fragile qu'elle progresse silva
premier corner ben c'est l'idée inverse
plutôt où les dires des premiers de
cordée des délais dernier de cordée
non mais ya pas de cordes et sa viande
est tous égaux dans notre pays on est
tous égaux il ya pas de cordes et il ya
une société qu'il faut construire en
prenant en compte les fragilités des uns
et des autres et les moments plus
difficiles
et pour ça il faut remettre la notion de
solidarité et la notion de fraternité au
goût du jour
c'est un peu disparu on va parler de la
mobilisation amène forte des salariés de
general electric
cinq mille personnes 800 emplois menacés
est-ce qu'on peut sauver ses emplois et
comment un peu plus que 1100 emplois
menacés les 52 3050 et notamment dans la
filière gaz comme on le sait mais aussi
dans les fonctions support et donc ils
pas simple à belfort principalement ce
qu'un drame mais aussi en région les
deux c'est un complot de macron non je
crois je crois que general electric
c'est sûr n'a pas n'a pas respecté ses
engagements sur la filière gaz nous
avions écrit en intersyndicale en 2018
en disant attention il faut pérenniser
cette activité dont on dit qu'elle
repartira en 2020 et donc on se sera
privé de 1000 compétences de mille
expertises et donc oui il faut faire le
maximum pour sauver ses emplois
parce que d'abord c'est un drame pour
chacun chacune des personnes concernées
deuxièmement sur un bassin d'emploi
comme celui de belfort
c'est une c'est également à bram et
troisièmement on aura besoin de ses
compétences demain lorsque l'activité
gaz va repartir dit à l'état d'agir
oui on avait écrit en ce sens l'état
doit agir doit se mobiliser sur cette
question là l'état stratège c'est oui
c'est l'état stratège on ne demande pas
à ce que l'état intervienne prennent
leur capital
stabilité dans ce danseur l'état a une
responsabilité et ce qu'ils portent une
responsabilité et ce qu'il a les
responsables de tous la réponse est non
mais il porte une responsabilité en tout
cas il a une responsabilité dans ce
sujet dans ce dossier il faut qu'ils
assument mais il ya aussi une grosse
responsabilité
le général eletric de l'entreprise qui
s'est mal comporté mais qui a brillé des
indemnités pour ça 50 millions à mais
moi quand quelqu'un se comporte mal je
considère qu'il se comporte mal quand
même
et qui doit faire en sorte de se
comporter mieux mais il faut durcir les
sanctions contre lui donc c'est bien sûr
alors bien sûr quand on respecte pas les
engagements qu'on a pris avec l'état
français avec l'état français qui
représentent ses citoyens quand on n'est
pas bien comportés il faut payer
elle est ce que vous redoutez d'autres
plans sociaux et dans quels secteurs
maintenant que les élections européennes
sont passées
j'espère que c'est pas corrélées mai
puis on l'a vu dans le passé
vous savez il ya des secteurs qui sont
soumis à beaucoup de beaucoup de
transformations et à tous ceux qui sont
concernés par une digitalisation accrue
je pense notamment avec à des secteurs
comme la la distribution la grande
distribution
donc oui il y avait beaucoup de
mouvement aujourd'hui danser dans le
secteur de la grande distribution
cela nous inquiète il y en a aussi dans
un certain nombre de secteurs
industriels je voudrais parler des
salariés d'arjowiggins notamment ceux
qui sont dans la sarthe 560 personnes
qui se retrouvent sans emploi dans un
secteur assez d'être un trait d
industrialiser dans le secteur rural
c'est à chaque fois des drames il faut
jamais oublier et c'est normal qu'on
fasse dans ce type d'émission mais aussi
dans les échanges entre interlocuteurs
sociaux et des gouvernements
on parle de global etc faut jamais
oublier les sujets à hauteur de femmes
et d'hommes ce qu'ils subissent et la
façon dont ça peut être ressentie parce
que tout ça a un impact sur leur vie sur
la société qu'on construit un impact
démocratique et politique très très
concret potentiellement et moi je le dis
il faut faire très attention à une
société qui continue de se fracturer
avec ce sentiment que c'est subissant
continuerait de subir parce que ça nous
amènera dans le mur au niveau
démocratique et là vous serez là puisque
vous dénoncez effectivement ce danger
populiste et d'extrême droite
régulièrement leur engagez vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure du risque de perte
de compétences technologiques à propos
de ce qui se passe à belfort et general
electric
est ce que vous dit la même chose
aujourd'hui avec les difficultés de le p
r 1 flamanville alors que vous vous
affichez donc avec nicolas hulot c'est
pas de la politique mais enfin est ce
que vous défendez la filière nucléaire
française est justement là on le voit
avec ces questions des soudures
exploitation dur montrent une perte de
compétences
oui bien sûr mais la position de
l'opposition c'est que il faut réduire
la part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique français
mais il faut pas se dire la cfdt allait
pas la sortie du nucléaire maintenant
immédiatement c'est je vais être clair
d'abord parce que c'est pas possible
parce qu'on n'a pas de chauffer à la
bougie donc même si elle s'est engagée
je vais d'ailleurs me rendre début
septembre pour l'équipe parce que
l'équipe elle assume ses décisions mais
elles travaillent sur le reclassement
des salariés ceux du site de du site
principal enfin mais aussi ceux de la
sous traitance mais sur le p r oui c'est
vrai que c'est un des feuilletons
industriels liés a sans doute la
compétence c'est aussi il faut le dire
trot le dis jamais c'est aussi le fait
qu'il faut se réjouir dans un pays qui
met la sécurité au dessus non mais je le
dise pas ce qu'on pourrait très bien de
l'avoir caché là nombre de pays qui
l'aurait caché non en plein il faisait
pas de jugement et je vous insérez du
fiasco et l'estrie et bien sûr bien sûr
mais les salariés ne sont pas
responsables nous faut faire ces travaux
et malheureusement les plans sociaux qui
se qui se multiplient et pourtant le
taux de chômage est au plus bas depuis
plus de dix ans à 8,3 pour cent de la
population est ce que finalement la
politique d' emmanuel macron elle crée
plus d'emplois qu'elle n'en détruit
est ce qu'elle est pas gagnante
finalement pour les français moi je me
réjouis de la création d'emplois
je me réjouis que le chômage baisse à
condition qu'ils baissent pour occuper
des emplois de bonne qualité quand même
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
vous savez les choses sont jamais figées
donc ça veut pas dire qu'on peut pas
créer de l'emploi d'un côté et en perdre
de l'autre dans ces cas là il faut
s'occuper des gens parce que c'est pas
des vases communicants
oui mais en tout cas ça ne pas encore
entrée en vigueur en termes de formation
pour la question
du chômage je dis juste attention il y
aura un impact un jour malheureusement
je le train d'ecr combien la guerre
commerciale entre les états unis et la
chine et donc il faut plutôt consolider
les compétences les ressources des
individus des personnes pour qu'il s'en
sorte et consolider les entreprises
feraient bien de nos votre état d'esprit
constructif
la cfdt j'allais dire combatif oui mais
si vous voulez constructive et vous
savez pour être constructif faut être
combatif passe comme ça ils sont
rassurants chômage je vous attends je
vous disais sur l'assurance chômage
alors là c'est la démonstration est
pourquoi on est en colère c'est qu'on a
beaucoup touché aux avancées que la cfdt
avait obtenu et quand la cfdt avait
obtenu cette avancée on avait beaucoup
critiqué la cfdt revendicatif combattre
pour le dialogue social est en colère
merci d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
leurs vergers
mesdames merci on trouvera la semaine
prochaine très belle soirée à tous